افتتح رئيس هيئه الترفيه معالي المستشار
تركي ال الشيخ امس اكبر منطقه في موسم
الرياض 20 22 وهي بوليفارد الرياض ومن وقت
الافتتاح لليوم ما زال هاشتاج افتتاح
بوليفارد ورد طبعا الترند على الصاج هذا
البوليفار بيقدم للزوار اكثر من 120 تجربه
في 10 مناطق بتجمع حضارات من حول العالم
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
يا مرحب يا هلا واهلا بزايرنا
هنا قلب الرياح
بالحرمان
ومن اول يوم تردد الاف السعوديين
والمقيمين على بوليفارد ورد الرياض
للاستمتاع بالتجارب المتنوعه ومشاهده
معالم العالم وهي جايت لهم في وسط الرياض
اكثر من 120 تجربه مثل ما قلنا 10 دول
ثقافات ومئات العروض الترفيهيه وغيرها
وغيرها وكل هذا مشاهدينا انجز في 82 يوم
بس بحسب ما اعلن معالي المستشار تركي ال
الشيخ طيب تندم الينا من هناك مراسله
العربيه الشهد المتروك عشان ناخذ معها جو
لو نشوف فيها معالم العالم في الرياض اهلا
فيك معانا يا همم شهد الف مبروك طبعا
الفوز وكيف الاجواء عندك مع الفوز
يعني ساره مساء
فعلا لي السعوديه والشعب السعودي يعني هذا
النتيجه الساحقه والعظيمه طبعا اللي خلت
كل الخليج ربما يكون جدا
نتيجه واستمرار المنتخب السعودي على ان
يكمل ويكون في مباريات ثانيه طبعا الفرحه
هذه ما كانت فقط في الملعب القطري لكن
ايضا كنا اليوم في اكثر من مكان في مرسول
الباركو شفنا فرحه الجمهور السعودي لما
كان يشجع المنتخب الحين احنا نتواجد فيه
ايضا الفرحه مستمره ومبينه في او على كثير
من الناس خصوصا الناس صارت ترتدي العلم
السعودي او الوشاح السعودي وحتى التيشيرت
اللي يخص المنتخب السعودي كما ترين ساره
يعني احنا اليوم نتجول في دول العالم لكن
في منطقه واحده
طبعا امس كنا في همم في المغرب في الصين
ايطاليا اليوم همم راح نستم في همم
اليونان تحديدا طبعا هذه الدول من عشر دول
اصلا موجوده في بوليفارد ورد اليوم
البوليفارد يتزين باللون الاخضر احتفالا
بفوز المنتخب همم السعودي همم طبعا هذه
جوله يمكن ما تعطي حتى المكان حقه من كثر
ما هو فعلا يفوق الخيال همم هذا المكان
اللي فيه عروض كثيره عشر دول عندنا اكبر
بحيره صناعيه في العالم تاخذ السياح او
الزوار يعني احنا راح نسميهم سياح لانه
يفترون دول العالم المختلفه ياخذنهم فيديو
ولا حول همم العواصم المختلفه فيه 11 محطه
ينتقلون اليها همم مائيا عبر او عن طريق
القوارب في كل دوله عندها محطه تنقل
للزوار من دوله الى همم اخرى طبعا في ايضا
جلسات شفنا همم في وسط البحيره يعني الناس
تقدر تستمتع فيها القوارب ايضا مصممه
مبتكر خصوصا في ايطاليا على شكل سيارات
ربما هذا اللي صورناه وطلع امس حتى همم
ساره طبعا يعني ال- ال- العروض لا تتوقف
همم في البوليفارد ورد الصين لهم طبعا
الادراجون او اللي يسمون التنين اللي
مشهورين في همم كنا في الهند وكانت في
فرقه هنديه قبل قليل اليونان طبعا متميزه
بتصميم هالمباني البيضه الزرقاء وهذا واحد
من العروض اليونانيه اللي موجود همم
يونان يعني اللي معروفه يعني في مبانيها
هذا واحد من
العروض الحيه اللي موجوده الحين طبعا ما
بين اليونان واليابان طيب خلينا نسمعوا
شويه يا شهد
يا بوني اسمعوني المشاهدين مباشره شويه من
راح اجرب المايك علشان توضح اكثر الاغاني
والموسيقى
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
طبعا مثل ما شفنا يعني هذا كان واحد من
العروض ساره يعني فعلا جميع العروض تفوق
الخيال كل الثقافات موجوده في البوليفارد
خصوصا اليوم صار المكان ازحم اكثر بعد فوز
المنتخب السعودي والاعلان عن دخول
البوليفارد سيتي البوليفارد ورد مجانا
والله الكل فرحان والاجواء عندك حلوه يا
ريتني كمان جلسه عندك كانت سلينا مع بعض
واخذنا مع بعض
اكثر بنشوفك على خير كانت معنا مراسله
العربيه
[موسيقى]